من غلاف غزه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس نبدا بالثورات الميدانيه
التي ترصدها من حيث
انت بالفعل مياده الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه مستمره على المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه تحديدا في المناطق الجنوبيه
للمدينه كانت هنالك غاره جويه عنيفه قبل
دقائق معدوده استهدفت الضواحي الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه وقبل ذلك ايضا بدقائق معدوده
كانت هنالك ايضا غاره جويه استهدفت
الاطراف الجنوبيه الغربيه للمدينه ربما
نشاهد ايه ما تبقى من اثر هذه الغاره
الجويه التي كانت ايضا مصحوبه بقصف مدفعي
على بعض المواقع في مدينه غزه وفي جباليا
في المناطق الشماليه للقطاع هذا ياتي رغم
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن عن انتهاء
عملياته العسكريه الكبرى في في المناطق
الشماليه للقطاع ونحن كنا نشير في الايام
الماضيه الى ان المناطق الشماليه للقطاع
تشهد اياما من الهدوء ثم تعود المعارك
لتشتت وتزداد حده
وقوه عندما تتوغل القوات الاسرائيليه في
محاور عده في المناطق التي تعيد الانتشار
فيها ثم تحاول مره اخرى العوده الى بعض
المناطق والقتال فيها نحن نستمع الان الى
تحليق كثيف للطير الحربي
الاسرائيلي ربما تسمعين هدير هذه
المقاتلات ونحن على مدار الساعه الاخيره
نسمع ديرا مكثفا للطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في اجواء المنطقه والقصف
المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف حقيقه على هذه
المناطق التي ما زالت تشهد اشتباكات مع
القوات الاسرائيليه او بين القوات
الاسرائيليه والمقا قاه الفلسطينيه وهذا
ما كانت لفتت اليه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
في الايام الاخيره حقيقه هو ان في الاماكن
التي ينسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي او يعيد
الانتشار فيها من الملاحظ بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تعاود السيطره عليها سواء كان
ذلك عسكريا او سواء كان ذلك في اوجه
سلطويه او مدنيه اخرى لا سما في مساله
توزيع المعونات الانسانيه على الفلسطينيين
الذين بقوا في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
وبالتالي هذا امر يقلق القوات الاسرائيليه
يقلق الجيش الاسرائيلي و من شانه بالفعل
كما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يؤدي الى
تداعيات سلبيه على ما يمكن ان يقال بانه
انجازات عسكريه حققها الجيش الاسرائيلي في
ال الشهور الاخيره وهو يلاحظ بحسب
التقارير انه في الاماكن التي ينسحب منها
ايه تعود المقاومه الفلسطينيه لتملا هذا
الفراغ وبالتالي كانت هنالك بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه التي اشارت الى ان
القياده العسكريه قد رفعت بطاقه حمراء في
وجه المستوى السياسي الاسرائيلي في
النقاشات الاخيره وطلبت من المستوى
السياسي ان يحدد وجهه نظره حول مستقبل
اداره شؤون قطاع غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب او
حتى بعد الانتقال من مراحل قتاليه الى
اخرى تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه التي
انتهت فيها المعارك ال ال الكبرى من
الناحيه العسكريه وكانت هنالك مخاوف لدى
القياده العسكريه من ان انسحاب الجيش
الاسرائيلي دون ان تكون هنالك سلطه مدنيه
او رؤيه سياسيه حول اداره الاوضاع في ال
تلك المناطق من شانها ان تعيد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لتملا هذا الفراغ كما ان
القياده العسكريه قد وضعت مسائله امام
المستوى السياسي حول الموقف السياسي الاس
اسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بتوسيع العمليات
العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه
وفيما اذا كان المستوى السياسي قد اتخذ
قرارا او سيتخذ قرارا في توسيع العمليات
العسكريه الى المناطق الجنوبيه اي الى رفح
وما هو مستقبل الوضع العسكري ايضا في محور
فيلادلفيا لان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو كان اشار قبل اسابيع عده بان هذه
الحرب لن تنتهي الا بسيطره اسرائيل او
ربما بايجاد حل لما سماها مشكله محور فيلا
دلفي الذي اعتبره منفذا لتهريب الاسلحه
الى قطاع غزه واثار بطبيعه الحال ذلك غضبا
كبيرا لدى الجانب المصري شكرا جزيلا لك من
غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام